Let's look at different types of aspects
and benefits of this coded aperture.
One, of course,
it allows you to compute,
capture an image in depth,
just from a single image.
And there is no real loss
of image resolution for
a simple modification to a lens.
Again, I don't recommend doing
to a very, your favorite lens.
Depth is of course coarse,
and we saw examples of that,
I mean, again, we are trying to
get something out of nothing.
If you get a little bit of depth,
but not very much, and
again, that is because we are trying
to basically get this out of,
by creating focus planes
by actually changing
how the focus looks like differently
because of the coded aperture.
But, you know, we get depth, of course,
we loose light and we know that, right?
Because we have a smaller opening than
this one, that basically means that
the light sensitivity in your lens
of the camera is going to go down,
darker scenes won't work very well.
But again,
we can actually do deconvolution and
increase depth of field after
the fact from a single image.
So, in essence, this is like a light
field camera where we actually get
defocusing and depth information by
changing in something in front of
the lens itself, the opening or
on the plane of the lens,
rather than changing the sensor, because
in light field, that's what we did.
Light field camera we changed the
sensors to be able to capture different
types of lights.